hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm John Humphrey dammit say it faster
we're gonna watch today super smash
brothers the ultimate history a brief
history how is this the ultimate history
and a brief history that makes no sense
this comes from the channel boo tofu
ferret you see one of our top reward
tiers over at our patreon is whatever a
video you requested you must definitely
do cover it put it up on the youtubes
and today comes from Andrew Hayes man
who was a guest on this channel so he's
a fellow reject and of course a loyal
patronage act you guys should go check
out his movie review channel as soon as
you can we've been talking lately back
and forth about the video games we've
been playing I recently got spider-man
ps4 a dead redemption too of course
last weekend we got to officially play
Super Smash Brothers ultimate that was
so that was so much fun man we need to
switch so much fun I'm even more
intrigued to check this out now that
we've actually gotten our hands on the
game I hope this is one of those super
fast-paced videos that hurts our heads
oh yeah has jingles every so often these
guys are the video game company behind
the several small-time franchises like
Super Mario Zelda Pokemon and their one
breakout success earthbound so which
games you've never heard of the last
thing you'd expect from Nintendo would
be some big infinity war style crossover
and yet apparently one of the most
anticipated games of the year has been a
huge Nintendo crossover fighting game
called Super Smash Brothers ultimate
it's supposed to have all the video
games in it but I don't see no Minecraft
I'll see no cup guy and I definitely
don't see any like this strange
no max Cup don't smash
ten yeah first pot guy and a man we all
know about super smash brothers ultimate
is without a doubt one of the biggest
releases of 2018 this series has been
one of the top tier fighting game
franchises if not over all video game
franchises for nearly 20 years now and
man I freaking grew up with smash bros
melee specifically this game was a first
part of my childhood and introduced me
to some of my all-time favorite video
game franchises like Star Fox and
Metroid that's your introduction don't
like Super Smash Brothers that much it's
weird I'm weird but I'm also getting
ahead of myself
so before you dislike unsubscribe and
yell at me let me just say hello and
welcome to another episode of a brief
history today's episode Super Smash
Brothers right sick yeah before the days
of eating Pikachu - a pumpkin coupon
final destination with no item he said
there was a Kirby yeah Kirby well more
specifically Kirby's creator Masahiro
Sakurai of how laboratory a second-party
developer for Nintendo around 1998
Sakurai was working on a fighting game
known as Dragon King but I guess the
game's generic title and faceless
color-coded mannequin hackers weren't
instilling a ton of confidence as he
decided the game needed a stronger
selling point to help it stand out his
solution toxic bunch of daddy Nintendo's
favorite toys in the ring and make him
fight to the death for fun but to even
Sakurai knew that Nintendo wasn't gonna
be too keen on this idea
so naturally he respected their opinion
but did it anyway without telling anyone
he developed a demo that featured Mario
Donkey Kong Samus and fox mccloud
helping out their problems
and pitched it back to Nintendo and
surprisingly they liked what they saw
and gave it the green light that's
pretty cool man over here you ever play
on nine stages inspired by their games
but underneath all this was a pretty
unique fighting system based around
building up damage to launch other
players off the screen I don't have a
ton of memories with this game I don't
think as a kid we just rented it from
Blockbuster a couple times but
apparently everyone else thought it was
the bee's frickin knees because Smash
Brothers was a surprise hit being 64
cartoon to millions of units and is now
one of the quintessential games on the
system but you never really hear people
talk about it anymore do you know why
the advancement in video games
at subsequent instalments of this game
the kind of sequel that makes everyone
forget that there was a first game at
all super smash brothers melee for the
Nintendo GameCube well did you hear that
a thousand epic gamers just peed
themselves now this was my Smash
Brothers game I played melee to death as
a kid I probably spent days if not weeks
worth of time playing and replaying this
game going through the new single-player
adventure mode with all my favorite cool
characters but I could then unlock even
more cool characters and but of course
always setting the game on very easy
because a big baby but yeah I adore this
game and something tells me that I'm not
the only one I mean what's not to love
mainly refined the gameplay formula to
near perfection doubled the character
roster tripled the stage selection and
quadrupled the detail on smash brothers
game because easily the best-selling
game on the Gamecube
in fact it's arguably one of the most
long-lasting games of its era spawning a
massive competitive scene that is still
going to this day and looks very
intimidating
[Music]
Wow yeah really did not take care of
himself during the games development you
know how you'll see youtubers talking
about burnouts or game developers
talking about crunch these days yeah
that was basically Sakurai's life for
over a year making melee so I guess it's
not too surprising that Sakurai actually
left a laboratory in August of 2003
which made things a little awkward when
in Tendo were just like hey and Sakurai
was just like hmm are you now yeah for
some reason in 2005 to decide to
announce a third Smash Brothers game
despite not actually working on one yet
they basically announced that they were
thinking about it but played it up like
it was totally happening but after a few
movies the Sakurai and his team and then
after development and thus in 2008 and
in 10 at least Super Smash Brothers
Brawl for the Nintendo Wii huh
did you hear that thousand epic gamers
just yeah I guess the black sheep of the
Smash Brothers franchise and it is
pretty weird
it did one thing majorly right by
introducing non nintendo fighters to the
character roster like Solid Snake and
Sonic the Hedgehog everything else about
the game is I guess slightly
controversial among fans so new
adventure mode Subspace Emissary
was absolutely huge and chock full of
his story I think now I remember really
liking this mode but it seems to have
had a mostly mixed reception among smash
fans yes did some gameplay tweaks and
something called tripping that I gotta
be honest I really don't understand at
all and never have but apparently people
hated however despite something
being disappointed in the game brawl was
still a huge hit for nintendo selling
over 13 million copies to this day and I
still played it a ton maybe not as much
as melee but baby folks he was obsessed
with Sonic so obviously we're all had to
be part of my shrine I mean collection
collection normally after I started to
get a little disillusioned with smash I
don't know started losing interest I
mean it didn't help that smash games
always had huge gaps in between but
after years of waiting in late 2014
released a brand new smash game for not
just one but two systems maybe this
would get me back on board horribly name
the super smash brothers for Wii U and
3ds these games had a ton of hype
leading up to their release and I was
right there with everyone a big smash
game split between two consoles that's
actually got my hands on the game I
gotta be honest I was really
underwhelmed
okay so smash 3ds was pretty cool just
for the sake of having a portable smash
game and smash Wii U brought the series
into HD and introduced 8-player smash it
does get overwhelming players a metal
story mode
- just nothing so I didn't really have
much to come back to but all that is
just my personal taste
overall smash4 was well a smash game so
obviously it was a hits millions of
copies sold rave reviews across the
board than usual but in the world of
smash I feel like the legacy of this
game has kind of been overshadowed by
two things how much people love melee
and how much they hate brawl like smash
4 created the franchise melee is the
best one brawl is the worst one and then
the smash 4 is just good the one that
also exists but thankfully this is not
where the story ends that's right on
March 8 2018 Nintendo revealed that a
brand-new Smash Brothers game was making
its way to Nintendo switch this game is
known as Super Smash Brothers ultimate
and actually it's really fun yes it's
really fun yes we haven't played it yet
gotta make this video but let me tell
you this game is doing a lot of things
right by me the big selling point for
ultimate is that everyone is here every
sub character from every single smash
game is in ultimate plus they're
bringing back adventure mode they're
giving Castlevania some love by
introducing Simon and Richter Belmont is
fighters and of course I'll play
anything that's got splatoon in it
people have been hyped for this game for
a myriad of reasons and I'll be honest
over the last few years I've become a
little more down with multiplayer game
specs - splatoon and 49 so I'm excited
to sit down and play the game for myself
except
that has the same kind of unique
identity as others the same kind of
speculation and research thanks for
watching guys I think we should spend
the most time talking about the inbox
dollars oh man that looks like a really
rewarding rewards program I tell you I
would love to make money just by giving
my opinion about various things I used
to try to do those surveys like ten
years ago I bought Ratchet and Clank and
Katamari Damacy just so I could
participate in a video game survey I
ultimately didn't get selected for but I
did buy and play those games this is an
interesting history partly because it
wasn't like here's the lore of the game
it's more like here's the history of how
this game got made and then got CS and
the guy like it's the real world history
of smash first off I really like this
guy's video editing stuff because we've
seen like several videos lately this
past year only this year two that we've
done people give like breakdowns of
things and there's
like hyper editing to them kind of like
this but they're very challenging to
keep up with often well because they're
spitting information you so fast that
it's a certain point it's hard to like
listen comprehend and keep on in real
time yeah and this guy like learned a
lot without feeling like I can't keep up
with this and my brain hurts you know
yeah he l Acutes very clearly as jokes
are very funny too like he's a really
funny guy he's got some awesome
self-deprecating humor he's like hyper
self-aware as well Thank You foot of a
ferret yes you break up his word or foot
off of her whoo tofu forever
yes I like that I didn't know that whole
thing about Sakurai working on that
Dragon King or whatever he's like look
like terrible animation well yeah
generic-looking and I and I almost
wonder if maybe that's just how far they
got before he decided just to work on ya
instead but he had these like generic
models I like that idea though of what
happened where he wasn't hired to do the
Nintendo version what ultimately become
Super Smash he kind of just messed
around did it anyway and then they ended
up loving it and then we got like I've
never forgotten about the n64 experience
I remember going with my cousin to
Blockbuster
[Music]
renting it and it's my first time
experiencing the n64 yeah I think Mele
was the biggest one but the n64 one was
always at landmark time alive I wasn't
aware of how famous the game had become
we definitely don't have Wi-Fi and
high-speed Internet yet in the world so
I wasn't aware of the cultural impact
and when I was like six years old or
something when it came out no you just
had the big three you just had Super
Mario 64 Mario Kart and Super Smash yes
you know and and Super Smash yeah it was
just something we would all congregate
around no matter what and it was the
violent game that you could play if your
mom didn't have of Goldeneye it was so
cool man I love that game and melee was
a phenomenon melee was legit I did not
know that there was a reputation for
brawl you see I can believe that because
by the time brawl came around I remember
not being as intrigued by it or being
treated by some of the characters you
could play like Oh Solid Snake holy [ __ ]
yeah yeah like I had fun playing it but
I definitely wasn't like I got a I got a
stay on this game and then for like Wii
U and 3ds I did have that feeling of
this is overwhelming because 80 players
they would have these backgrounds that
are just moving so much that I couldn't
see the players I couldn't see I would
sometimes I would really often lose
track of where's my character and then
it would just become overwhelming them
when you got eight players you're
hanging out with it it's it was
exhausting and then that wasn't
something I really care to pick up a
game of a plane ultimate I'm not good at
picking up on the fine-tune details of
what makes each one of these so
different it just seemed like they
always got crazier and crazier just like
a little bit more each time especially
with the stages the levels I was never
really into the adventure mode some
people are but he makes a great point
about how the first two games like yeah
you can battle with friends they have
the competition so they offer a lot of
great single-player adventure where as
as it progress it's like now this is
like a multiplayer game Mario Party in a
way you need people yeah you need your
friends to be over or you do online
multiplayer games and that's true and
that might have been the lack of appeal
for me to have really been getting
addicted to the game or
get like new Nintendo systems for the
Super Smash is one of the Nintendo games
I adore I never thought about that and
it's so true
like the first two games I play about
myself a lot yeah then as I got older
it's like I had to play this game a
really joy you got to play with your
buddies you know I didn't really ever
get much into Wii U or 3ds so there is
that I feel like Wii U was kind of a
ringer system for them even though like
people kind of scoff at the GameCube it
at least occupied its own lane whereas
the Wii U kind of had this awkward time
that whole double game there I just
completely missed in a way I feel like
the history kind of works in the game's
favor for where we are now because like
the hype around ultimate is and you you
know you kind of got to have some Evan
flow together you know truly back to the
greatness if you want to have that
dynamic I would like to see Sakurai kind
of I mean start to transition into other
territories maybe when I say transition
I mean that because maybe they can do
something worse like you you're in a
totally different direction yeah like an
Xbox characters fighting the hey maybe
another fighting type game that's
similar to Super Smash but a completely
different type of medium to explore like
outside be cool to do like Harry Potter
and Lord of the Rings characters in one
you know be interesting or they could
get involved in the Marvel one like I
think a Marvel super smash kind of game
would be really cool well eventually
there's just gonna be one fighting game
like all these series is gonna glom
closer and closer together borrow more
and more characters and then eventually
just everyone's gonna versus everything
well it's it's just such a fishing
playing because everyone is required the
same level of control combo maneuvers
you know it was like when you play other
fighting games like Tekken or Mortal
Kombat you got to do different things
with each pad and the buttons in order
to do certain combos yeah Super Smash
they all do different things but it's
the same requirements that reach this
happy middle ground between being a
legit fighting game that's not like so
complicated that you have to like really
understand a combo you have to like pull
up an options menu ago okay so how do
you do the combos for this character
they're all the same
yeah it's like they do different things
with the way to do them is the same yeah
I think that's what makes the game so
accessible for everyone because you get
your variety
through the way they do their [ __ ] but
you know like the fact that it's the
fact that I can always play the next
Super Smash and know how to play yeah
yeah well and the games also have just
like a completely different vibe from
every other fighting game well you know
you smash for all of you out there
everything was just fine you don't even
know yeah which is funny because yeah it
is like bright and garish and whimsical
and like it's fun to see like how many
different environments there are how
many different characters and like it's
the one fighting game where I don't sit
around going yeah I just am like excited
and happy and fun well this is a great
video thanks for pointing together
thanks for requesting an Andrew hope
you're doing well buddy merry Christmas
to you and your hot mom you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell chicks on patreon
we got weaken q and A's TV show reaction
watch alongs and john does music video
coverage we'd love to have you become a
patron object